today on the matt walsh show jill biden
reaches out to hispanic voters by
comparing them to tacos for some reason
it didn't go over well can't imagine why
plus j.k rowling continues to experience
backlash for committing the sin of
speaking to me how dare she and the
creator of friends embarks on a global
apology tour to atone for all of the
unwoke sins her show committed all those
years ago also remember that story about
border patrol agents whipping haitian
immigrants well a 500 page report now
confirms what was obvious to anybody
with eyes to begin with it never
happened it was all a lie in our daily
cancellation can a morbidly obese person
still have thin privilege we'll find out
today all of that and much more on the
matt wall show
[Music]
do you want to know an easy way to
adjust your spending and saving
strategies just call my friends over at
american financing which is america's
home for home loans there you can get a
free no obligation financial review so
you can understand new ways to get out
of debt faster like i mean when i say
there's no pressure there's no upfront
or hidden fees it may sound daunting
making a call like this and you think
it's going to get complicated and get
roped into all kinds of different things
that's not the case it's very simple no
pressure at all it'll just be a simple
conversation about ways you can add
hundreds back to your monthly budget and
that's something that these days we
could all certainly use maybe it'll be
by consolidating debt by adjusting your
mortgage terms or even accessing cash
whatever it is believe me
these guys can help and you don't need
perfect credit to make it happen either
they want to help as many families as
possible it's one of the many reasons
why i like these guys so much and
appreciate them so why not take 10
minutes and learn more if you start soon
you could close in as fast as 10 days
just call 866 569-4711 that's
866-569-4711
or visit
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
well i could not have predicted that
this would be the week when an
organization would have to release a
statement with the phrase we are not
tacos but uh then again here we are and
i for one am loving every second of it
this all begins with dr jill biden phd
making a stop in san antonio to speak at
a luncheon held by a far-left hispanic
advocacy group called unitedos u.s
and uh more on that group in this
luncheon in just a second but during her
speech
biden uh somehow still the most coherent
and eloquent biden in the family but the
bar is very low
wanted to show that uh both she and her
husband are are deeply in touch with the
hispanic community you know they they
understand latin culture and its people
they especially love latino people for
the one or two minutes that they spend
in the voting booth provided that of
course they vote democrat all the way
down the ticket
and that's the hispanic tradition that i
think they most value and cherish though
it's a tradition that has been
rapidly fading thankfully the last few
election cycles have made it abundantly
clear that the democrat party is
steadily losing its grip
on the latino vote as a recent reuters
headline put it hispanic voters are
losing faith in democrats and the
article suggests that the swing and the
hispanic community towards the
republican party it was like a 10 point
swing or almost 10 point swing eight or
nine points uh just for for uh trump in
2020
and they suggest this has a lot to do
with the abysmal state of the economy
right now and there's no doubt that
that's at least part of the story
it comes as news to democrat politicians
but
minority voters are actually uh human
beings who have real practical concerns
for instance
they want to be able to afford gas and
food and they don't want their children
to you know starve to death so these are
things that they're concerned about they
also don't particularly want to be
murdered by by criminals that democrat
da's let off the hook now admittedly on
this point i haven't really checked the
polling data in fact i haven't tried
pulling data data on all of this on any
of it but i but i can just assume that
it's true
and also this as well i'm betting that a
huge number of hispanics and other
minorities
don't want to send their kids to school
to learn about gender fluidity or to be
subjected to
drag queen stripteases
these are all reasons why hispanics may
be increasingly looking for political
options outside of the democrat bubble
and this is what drove
primarily dr jill biden phd to the
latino conference and it's what led to
this glorious moment which begins with
uh dr jill biden phd attempting to
praise the work of the president of the
organization whose name is raoul that's
his first name and his last name i won't
even attempt to pronounce and that's
when things go careening off the rails
tremendously watch this
raul helped build this organization
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogotas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
[Applause]
is your strength
now i realize that i am in no position
to criticize anybody for
mispronouncing words but
even i
find myself flabbergasted by bodegas
now she means of course bodega but she
pronounces it like somebody who would go
to a mexican restaurant and order a
quesadilla and then try to impress her
waitress by asking her to point the
direction of the albano
and yet this
was somehow not the most embarrassing
part of dr jill biden phd's remarks she
also as has been much discussed in the
hours since
tried to compliment hispanic people by
saying that they are as unique as
breakfast tacos
and from what i understand you know just
what i've heard reports is that next
week she'll be speaking to an asian
american organization where she'll
praise attendees for being as bold and
vibrant as general sews chicken and as
reliable as pork fried rice
but this at least will not be as
insulting as when she hails italians for
being as cheap as box spaghetti and says
that the french are as soft and puffy as
a freshly baked croissant
now
the question though is that the taco
comment in particular what was it
actually racist
or or you know really offensive
and of course it wasn't it's it's stupid
and it's hilarious embarrassing for her
but greatly enjoyable for the rest of us
not racist though right
yet i confess that i'm not eager to
defend her from the racism charge any
more than she would be presumably eager
to defend me from such a charge
so instead i'll just sit back and enjoy
the show as various left-wing groups
pretend to have been severely victimized
by dr jill biden phd's clumsy attempt at
pandering to
that's what brings us to as mentioned at
the top
the national association of hispanic
journalists which released the following
statement last night after this whole
thing happened they said
nahj encourages uh the first lady and
her communications team to take time to
better understand the complexities of
our people and communities
we are not tacos our heritage as latinos
is shaped by various uh diasporas
cultures and food traditions do not
reduce us to stereotypes
so this is the they're they are
you know standing up
to tamp down the stereotype that
hispanic people are tacos because that's
a stereotype that you know you've heard
a stereotype before that hispanics are
just like they're just tacos literally
but they're not turns out and i'm glad
we cleared that up
um but are they burritos
are they chalupas are they a bowl of
guacamole further clarification i think
needs to be made here for her part the
first lady has now issued an apology
for calling hispanic people tacos her
spokesman tweeted this morning quote the
first lady apologizes that her words
conveyed anything but pure admiration
and love for the latino community
he then added that the guilt and regret
she feels burns inside her like a very
spicy salsa
and yet
amid all of this delicious taco
controversy
i think the most truly offensive
like actually offensive
and gratuitous aspect of of this story
has somehow been lost as it so often is
because the actual name of the
conference where she delivered these
ill-fated remarks was quote this is what
it was
the latinx
inclusion luncheon now
inclusion is spelled with an x
and therefore pronounced i guess
inclusion
of course the irony here is that if you
actually add an x to inclusion it
becomes exclusion so it's which which
actually there's there's uh there's
i think some something poetic about that
it's no wonder the first lady you know
felt that she could be demeaning and
patronizing in her remarks she was
speaking after all at the latinx
inclusion conf luncheon
obviously she felt like she had some
license here
the left is holding her accountable for
her taco related stereotypes
yet they haven't noticed that the whole
event
promoted right in its name
the western white liberal colonization
of the spanish language
now i'm not
hispanic but i can still say that that i
i think i would rather be compared to a
taco than have my language destroyed for
the sake of appeasing lgbt militants and
then again the same thing is happening
to the english language so i suppose
we're all in the same boat
we have to understand i think
getting away from the taco stuff for a
moment
we have to understand the reason why
they're randomly dropping the letter x
into words
where it doesn't of course make any
sense
and where it in fact destroys the
meaning of the word itself as we've
talked about before you know when you do
this especially with the spanish
language which is a heavily gendered
language and you try to make everything
gender-neutral you're just you're just
obliterating the language you're
creating a new language and so what the
left is saying to spanish speaking
people
is that uh well you shouldn't your
language is bad it's a your your
language is transphobic and homophobic
you need a new language and we're going
to give it to you here it is
say these words instead bark for me bark
like dogs at our command that's what
they're saying disbanding people
but the x thing in particular it seems
totally arbitrary right
like even if i even if we agreed that we
needed to make words more inclusive
which we don't and which doesn't make
any sense anyway i mean words are every
word every word by its nature needs to
be exclusive in that it means a certain
thing and doesn't mean other things
because if every word
means everything then no word means
anything and we can't speak anymore
but why so
but even if we agree that words need to
be inclusive like why would the letter x
accomplish that
how does that work
does the word inclusion itself need to
be more inclusive and if it does how do
you accomplish that by just dropping the
word x into the letter x into it
seems totally arbitrary and it is
but this is what we have to understand
the arbitrariness is the point this is
what tyrants do they manipulate their
subjects or simply command them
to do arbitrary and meaningless things
because they're arbitrary and
meaningless it's like that scene in cool
hand luke when the jail warden makes
paul newman's character dig a hole for
no reason and then fill it back in and
dig it again
the idea was to you know break his will
and his spirit train him to be obedient
and to follow orders
it didn't work in cool hand luke's case
but for many americans it has worked
now the the x thing in particular hasn't
quite caught on yet
the hispanic community almost uniformly
rejects it
but give it time i mean the left has
shown
that this strategy works
make people do arbitrary things dance
through hoops for no reason
break their will train them to be
obedient
as funny as the taco controversy is i
think this is the real agenda what we
should be talking about now let's get to
our five headlines
[Music]
when did we decide to stop upholding
free speech as a basic right well i
didn't decide that but that seems to
have been decided in society what's
playing out right now at big tech
companies and social media sites sets a
dangerous precedent look it doesn't
matter what your politics are or who you
voted for everyone should have the right
to express themselves freely sadly the
big tech monopoly has instead opted for
silencing tactics and censorship instead
to fight back against big text control
of the internet i use expressvpn we use
expressvpn on your computer or your
phone you make yourself anonymous much
of your online presence anonymous by
hiding your ip address just call me jill
biden that makes your activity more
difficult to trace and uh sell to
advertisers expressvpn encrypts 100 of
your network data to protect you from
eavesdroppers and cybercriminals as well
what i like most is how easy it is to
use it just takes one click to protect
all of your devices that's why
expressvpn is rated number one by
business insider so let's stop allowing
big tech to provoke our rights to free
speech why not revoke their right to
your data instead secure your internet
with the vpn i trust for online
production visit expressvpn.com walsh
that's e-x-p-r-e-s-s-vpn.com
walsh to get three months free with my
exclusive link go to expressvpn.com
walsh right now to learn more
all right we'll start here so the uh jk
rowling
saga continues the story is uh last i
checked is still trending on twitter
after like two or three days they still
can't quite get enough of this and just
to back up and review here
because it's changed a little bit right
so i um i mentioned yesterday how jk
rowling
criticized me for my critique of macy
gray who's the pop singer who went on
pierce morgan last week earlier last
week and and made the very controversial
statement that women exist and are
female and they have babies uh and they
have breasts and that's that's how she
defined them and then she lasted about
two or three days until she went
crawling to
do the pilgrimage to morning network tv
where she apologized and said well
actually women don't exist it's just a
vibe and everything else
i criticized macy gray said that she's a
coward because she is
um
and then jk rowley criticized me for
attacking women and she said that i
can't possibly know what it's like to be
a woman standing up against the trans
mob not her words exactly but i i can't
know what it's like to be a woman
because i don't have to deal with all of
that
um well yesterday
when we talked about this i didn't go
through the whole exchange that i had
with with jk rowling it was more than
just you know the one tweet back and
forth i responded to rowling's tweet to
me by telling her that well actually i i
have experienced
um death threats
everything else
from from the trans mob for years now
but especially because of my film
and she responded to to me after that
saying that well that my film referring
to what is woman
here's her exact word she said it did a
good job of exposing the incoherence of
gender ideology that's all she said
right
and that was that was the it that was it
was the end of our exchange
and because of that
even though again the only reason
initially that jk rowling said anything
to me at all or about me was to
criticize me
um because she had that one sentence
acknowledging the film and saying that
it did a good job of exposing the
incoherence of gender ideology because
of that that's why this story has
continued to trend
and there have been many headlines just
like this from pink news
jk rowling criticized for praising
dangerous anti-trans film by far-right
bigot matt walsh
and then this from uh from the advocate
it says jk rowling and matt walsh bond
over transphobia get blasted online then
the daily dot says jk rowling endorses
transphobic documentary by alt-right
commentator matt walsh so i'm an
alt-right commentator now i don't know i
always i always learn new things about
myself anytime my name appears in
headlines here's a bit of the pink news
article it says the daily wire film
features walsh asking what is a woman to
a variety of people including a
pediatrician a surgeon who specializes
in gender reaffirming surgery and
controversial psychologist jordan
peterson the film has been called
transphobic by rolling stone and
dangerous by lgbtq nation well
if it's called that by lgbtq nation then
you know it's true we know we can trust
lgbtq nation rolling stone let's never
mind the fact that as we established yes
they they did call it transphobic and i
think they also called it dangerous
but as we established none of the people
involved in writing this article this
hit piece on what is a woman for rolling
stone had actually watched the film the
editor made it through 11 and the writer
of the of the article didn't watch any
of it whatsoever but never mind that um
pink news says
uh it provides ammunition for those who
seek to deprive transgender people of
access to affirming and life-saving
healthcare
walsh the author of johnny the walrus
notorious anti-trans children's book has
become known for describing himself as a
theocratic fascist a label that has been
directed at him previously by his
critics
in a blog post explaining his use of the
label which he uses in his twitter bio
walsh claims that it could be an
obviously sarcastic joke or it could be
a completely literal and sincere
statement without the slightest hint of
irony or sarcasm it is definitely the
latter can i just say could be one of
the two but i am i think i've been very
clear about this for years now that i'm
a theocratic fascist i have plans to
take over uh not just this country but
the hemisphere and uh put you all
underneath my uh tyrannical boot hill um
as my as my servants and slaves that's
that's my plan i think i've been very
open about this
and yet
again all rowling did
was acknowledge the film in the context
of criticizing me and this is a story to
the left they can't handle they can't
deal with it
because they believe that they have the
right well there are a few reasons for
this a few reasons why this becomes a
story they talk about for three days
one of them is that um
they believe they have the right to
control
who jk rowling speaks to
like what they're saying to us you're
not allowed to talk to him
even to criticize him can't talk to him
can't talk to that guy
they can control who she speaks to and
who she speaks about
why do they think they have that right
well i think they have that right with
everybody
but especially because she is a woman
you know the left believes that it owns
women that women are its um property
just like they believe this with uh with
racial minorities in this country
and that is
a unique challenge
for women who stand against them
that on top of uh getting all the normal
anger and backlash there's also this
sense of uh they're treated like
traitors like there's this sense of
betrayal how dare you
you're supposed to be on our side just
because of your of your sex even though
sex doesn't exist but still we determine
based on that that you belong to us
and the fact that that is a unique
challenge
for women that's something that i'm
perfectly prepared to acknowledge in
fact i'm eager to acknowledge it i've
said it many times
the problem though and this is what i'm
running into with the feminists um
even the feminists who are critical of
the trans agenda
is is that they can't leave it at that
this is this this is the case for for jk
rowling herself as well
like we could talk about if if you're a
woman and you stand up against the trans
mob there are you're going to be treated
in a certain way and they're going to be
unique challenges that come with you
being a woman
standing up against these people
that's that's fine we could talk about
that but the feminists they can't leave
it at that
they want to go all the way to claiming
that uh as jk rowling did herself that
men aren't criticized at all
when when when we say our opinion that
we experience no backlash
because we're men
which is just completely absurd
and because they insist on this then
that's why you know everything kind of
breaks down any chance that we have
for conservatives on to sort of form
this alliance with uh with left-wing
feminists at least on the issue of
transgenderism any chance of that
happening in my experience especially
just completely breaks down
because they are beholden to this
victimized victimology this victim
hierarchy and uh they can't get past it
they can't see past it
and the thing is that no matter who you
are
if you take a stand against the
orthodoxies of the day there are going
to be unique challenges for you whatever
your position is whoever you are
whatever your identity is they're going
to be they're going to be you're going
to have to deal with with certain things
and some of that's going to be unique to
you in your particular station in life
nobody is uh is exempt from that
and so the position and if we want to
break it down male and female
position women are in is that again the
left thinks that if you're a woman well
they own you they have ownership of you
even though you belong to a category
that doesn't exist according to them
still they own you so if you say
anything then then you're a traitor um
if you're a man on the other hand then
you're already you're a villain you're
you're worthless
so there's the people that are that that
they think they own and there's people
that have been cast as the villain
which which category is it better to be
in which category is treated better i i
don't think either category is treated
well
just you're treated like worthless scum
in slightly different ways i don't know
why we can't
simply all agree with that i'm moving on
to this marta kaufman who's the creator
of
the uh
what i think
next to seinfeld maybe at least is the
second most overrated sitcom of all time
friends
she's been on an apology tour recently
and i'm not exactly sure why she's been
doing this now in particular i don't
know i guess she has something she's
promoting she's got another show coming
out i don't know that exactly but i
could only assume that she's got
something else she's working on and so
she wants to set things right with the
woke brigade so she's been going around
trying to write all of the unwoke wrongs
that her series committed somehow back
in the 90s now i was never as noted
never a big fan of friends i've seen a
few of the episodes
it always struck me even in the 90s as
pretty politically correct
okay never would have occurred to me
that there's anything
offensive to the left in friends but
apparently there is there's quite a lot
so for the last few weeks she's been
going around apologizing for all of the
various groups that were hurt by friends
somehow
in an effort to become an ally now so
we'll start with this she appeared on
talk tv this was at the end of june a
couple weeks ago
to talk about the racism on her show i
had no idea there was racism but there
was
as she confesses here but she's going to
set things right
and listen to this
it took me
a long time to begin to understand
how i
internalized
systemic racism
and i've been working really really hard
to
become an ally anti-racist
and this seemed to me to be a way that i
could participate
in the conversation
from
a white woman's perspective
i hope
it becomes
the leading
aaas department in the country i hope
that
this department gets everything it needs
financially and can
continue
to engage students
and
i hope it widens
okay so she
one thing she's been doing for the last
uh i don't know exactly everything she's
been up to since friends went off the
air but it's very clear that she's been
studying
wokeness and she's been studying it
closely because
uh she knows she she speaks the language
now she had it all down you know
do the work
participate in the conversation all this
kind of stuff it's still not clear to me
so what exactly was racist about friends
it's not it's not clear i guess it's
because there was a there weren't enough
black actors on on the show and so he
raced
uh
apparently this at least i've learned i
can assume this is what she's talking
about because this is what i've seen
from other left people on social media
that friends erased black people
by not having enough of them on
the sitcom so i don't know if you are a
black person you might not even realize
that you were erased by a sitcom in the
90s but you were
and you and if you don't feel harmed and
damaged by that you should
this even according to the co-creator of
the show she even says that so now she's
pledging it's four million dollars to
support african and african american
studies
uh so she's trying to heal the racial
wounds created by friends because of
that but it's not just racial wounds um
look anytime
there's an occasion where someone is a
victim
we know that uh that the trans club
they're gonna they're gonna find their
way in to that conversation okay no one
is uh
nobody in this country is allowed to be
a victim by themselves without including
trans people trans people are also
victims if you think you're a victim
there's always going to be um uh the
trans club coming right behind to say no
i'm me too oh yeah i'm also a victim of
this
so she was she appeared on bbc last
night in an interview
to uh confess to very various pronoun
related atrocities let's listen to that
criticism
is
it's difficult i mean
friends has been criticized in a number
of ways
the biggest one being that we did not
have enough representation of black
people and over the course of the last
few years
i have gotten to the point where i can
say
unfortunately yes i'm guilty of that
i am guilty of that
and i'll never make that mistake again i
was
clearly part of
systemic racism in our business i was
unaware of that which makes me feel
stupid
so yeah that was a very valid extremely
difficult
criticism which still
i get emotional about
if i knew then what i know now there are
certain things i would have changed but
i didn't know them and i have since
learned here's one
we kept referring to her as chandler's
father
even though chandler's
father was trans
pronouns were not yet something
that i understood
so we didn't refer to that character as
she
oh pronoun
she's getting emotional she's getting
choked up
um she's still
20 years later she's still
crying about the fact she's distraught
because there were enough black actors
and friends and also because she she
misgendered
uh who is it chandler's
trans dad is that what it was
so that's why you would think that we
that the left would celebrate
friends for being ahead of its time i
didn't even realize this until just now
but so so one of the characters on
friends had a cross-dressing or trans or
whatever uh parent so you'd think that
the left would would be celebrating and
it says ahead of its time
in the 90s to have that kind of
character
but but no because even though it was
ahead of its time it still had not yet
caught because it existed in the past it
wasn't aligned with what people are
saying and doing
in the year 2022
um which which is just a an unforgivable
sin
and so atonement must be made and that's
what she's doing now
it's no surprise to see this you know
especially from people in hollywood in
order to find success in hollywood to
begin with you have to empty yourself
most of the time you have to empty
yourself of um
you know your
any real personality any real
convictions
and you just become this empty shell of
a human being
um and that's why she has no problem i
mean this anyone else i think if you if
you had
like a spine and a soul you would at
least be embarrassed
to be doing this apology tour for a
sitcom that you made 30 years ago
but she has none of that there's no
dignity so there's nothing to worry
about for her
all right so you remember that story
about the
the border patrol
whipping immigrants as they tried to
cross the border this was uh
several months ago that was the story
anyway
that there were immigrants i think there
were refugees haitian haitian immigrants
rather trying to cross the border
southern border and uh they were being
whipped by border patrol agents
that was the story uh it was a story
amplified of course by the media
amplified by joe biden the president
himself
went on tv was talking about how what a
horrible atrocity this was
and of course there were a lot of things
about that story that a lot of questions
that were raised that we could have
talked about we should have talked about
like for example uh why are haitian
immigrants coming across the southern
border well we didn't talk about that
though instead we talked about the fact
that they were getting whipped um
even though you know there were images
at the time of this whipping there were
there were pictures and there were also
there was video as well
and you could look at that as we did on
the show and clearly see oh that didn't
happen they were not being whipped at
all yes some of the border patrol agents
did have whips because they're on
horseback but they were using them on
the horses
not on the immigrants and you could
clearly see that on video
and nonetheless the media ran with it
biden ran with it he just he threw all
of these agents completely under the bus
and they declared that there was going
to be a long investigation into this
whipping that anyone with eyes could see
never happened
and so they did the investigation and a
couple of days ago they released a 511
page report okay the you the customs and
border protection agency
they've been investigating this for
months they compiled a 500 page report
about a whipping incident
that there was already video evidence
never happened
and they determined that indeed it never
happened
that's what the report
declared
and yet here's the headline
here's how the media is translating it i
think this headline in npr is
representative it says
the agents on horseback who chased
migrants used unnecessary force a report
fines that's that's how they are
summarizing it it says u.s border patrol
agents on horseback engaged in
unnecessary use of force against
non-threatening haitian immigrants
but didn't whip any with their reigns
intentionally or otherwise according to
a federal investigation of chaotic
scenes along the texas-mexico border
last fall that sparked widespread
condemnation
again the headline in the media
including on npr and every other
mainstream media outlet was that they
were whipping the immigrants
and now we're being told that never
happened
is there any retraction from any of
these media outlets no of course not
instead we get the uh well we weren't
exactly right but we were basically
right because they were still using
force well what kind of force were they
using let's read on and try to find out
because in again in this in the videos
and in the photographs
i didn't see really any force being used
except in the case except just in the
sense that the border patrol agents are
physical beings so anything they do
involves
physical exertion i mean even speaking
requires physical exertion so is that
what they mean by physical force well
maybe we'll find out um in a 511-page
report released friday customs of border
protection blamed a lack of command
control and communication for mounted
agents using their horses to forcibly
block and move migrants during an influx
of haitians arriving last saturday
rather last september at the u.s border
outside del rio texas
cbp commissioner chris magnus said
during a news conference we're going to
learn from this incident and we'll find
a way to do better not everyone's going
to like all the findings but the
investigation was comprehensive and fair
um
video and photos of the incident made it
up here agents were whipping haitians
well no it didn't make that appear that
way at all the headlines made it appear
that way but the
video and the photographs did not make
it appear that way uh caused outrage
among advocacy groups and civil rights
leaders the bible administration
promised a full investigation after many
in the president's own party objected
that such tactics with racial overtones
were the kinds of policies that the u.s
was supposed to be moving away from
after years of hard-line immigration
tactics under president donald trump
yeah i wish there were a hard-line
immigration tactics under president
donald trump
one of my one of my biggest problems
with um
the trump administration and his tenure
is that we did not at all get the
hard-line tactics that we were promised
but anyway
former police chief magnus took over the
nation's largest law enforcement agency
blah blah blah what i'm trying to get to
is is what where exactly was the
physical force i mean that's in the
headline that they used inappropriate
force
and then in the first sentence they say
it again but where exactly is the force
are they going to explain what they
meant by that
and as you go through the article it
doesn't appear anywhere
so it would seem
that by physical force what they mean is
that exactly what i said actually that
these the border patrol agents were are
physical beings
and they were there like exerting
themselves physically and so that's what
we mean by physical force
and yes they did try to block the um
illegal immigrants
from running across the border and
running away
you don't really see any physical
contact being made but they do position
themselves in front of the illegal
immigrants to try to block them
and um
you might point out that that is exactly
why they're there
that's they're called border patrol this
is in for enforcement they are there to
try to block people
from coming across the border illegally
that's one of the only reasons the
border patrol exists in the first place
that is being called
unnecessary and inappropriate force
as a way of papering over the fact that
the whole story about whipping haitian
immigrants was completely false and
fabricated from the beginning
all right i'll move to this this from
the daily wire says the food and drug
administration received its first
application for an over-the-counter
birth control pill
on monday the application comes just
weeks after the supreme court's ruling
overturned roe v wade which has some
critics concerned about access to
contraceptives there's no reason why
there should be any concern about that
because roe v wade has nothing to do
with contraception
but it says the company behind the
application hra pharma a perego company
seeks to become the first daily birth
control pill available in the u.s
without a prescription
now this is
very bad news obviously very bad news it
should be obvious to most people anyway
and
the reason is that uh
you know we have been in this country
below replacement level
since probably the early 70s
you know what counts as replacement
level that can vary depending on who you
talk to but since about the early 70s
we've been below population replacement
level
last year in 2021 saw the slowest
population growth in u.s history
75
of uh counties in this country lost
population first time that's ever
happened total growth was 0.1
which is definitely below replacement
level
and that is one of the many reasons why
i don't celebrate any news about more
accessible birth
control another reason is that uh the
whole idea that birth control is
inaccessible or there's a lack of birth
control or it's hard for people to get
their hands on birth control like that
that the whole idea is completely absurd
nonsensical and a complete false
narrative
um there is
the options for birth control for anyone
who wants it are plentiful unless you
live out in the wilderness
um 100 miles from the nearest town and
there's not very many places you can go
in this country to live somewhere like
that and not very many people do but
unless you live in a situation like that
birth control is very accessible to you
like you can give birth you can get a
form of birth control of contraceptive
at almost any gas station that's how
accessible it is
and yet we're continually told how
there's this phantom problem of people
not being able to obtain birth control
it's it's just like um the people who
have trouble voting
because of voter id laws
yeah i think these are these are two
people in this these are two groups in
the same camp
in that they don't exist
or at least i've never seen any real
evidence of them
okay i want to talk
to the
to the person
whoever it is
who's actually had trouble obtaining
some form of contraceptive in this
country
i want to know how that is like how
exactly did that work that you had
trouble obtaining it
uh so that's that's the first problem
with it but but the but the other
problem as i said is that
population is declining
rapidly
and that is a crisis why is that a
crisis well because uh we're dying off
as a people as a country
which would seem to be a problem to me
we are literally dying off which leads
to an older more frail more vulnerable
population
people
just
kind of wasting away without anybody to
care for them
which is what we're experiencing right
now it's going to get a lot worse in the
next 50 to 70 years
so if you think that civilization dying
off is a problem then then then you know
there's no reason to celebrate
greater access to birth control that's
that's the exact opposite of our problem
we do not have a problem with a lack of
birth control if anything the problem
goes the other way
and why is the is is our population
declining
well it has a lot to do with birth
control
uh has a lot to do with the fact that
that uh people are increasingly giving
up on human relationships entirely
replacing it with internet porn and that
sort of thing
has a lot to do with materialism people
are prioritizing other things
their material comfort and luxury and
everything rather than
having starting families and leaving a
legacy and having progeny and
descendants and everything else
and at the bottom of all of that i think
is the fact that that
we as a
civilization
[Music]
are despairing of ourselves we're just
giving up on existence we're simply
giving up on it
and you can see that in people because
when you when you when
you as i said you would think it'd be
obvious
that our population declining and dying
off is a a problem you'd think that
would be obvious to people
and yet when you tell people that very
often they kind of shrug their shoulders
why does that matter
why does it matter if your civilization
dies off i
if i need to explain that to you then we
have
big problems here that go beyond this
conversation
all right let's go to let's go to some
good news before we get to our comment
section
uh this article from cnn unfortunately
ropes biden into it and tries to give
him credit for something that he had
nothing at all to do with but if you can
overlook that the story is quite
fascinating
it says the first glimpse of how the
james webb space telescope will change
the way people see the universe has
arrived president joe biden has released
one of webb's first images of course he
didn't the president didn't release the
image from the satellite but whatever um
and it's the deepest and sharpest
infrared image of the distant universe
to date according to nasa the image
shows um a galaxy cluster
and uh it's called gravitational lensing
this created webb's first deep field
view of incredibly old and distant faint
galaxies the presentation occurred at
the white house during a preview event
with nasa administrator bill nelson and
then today throughout the week they're
going to release more images from this
telescope
this telescope and you could we'll put
the image up on the screen you can see
it
this is the telescope positioned
a million miles away
now the hubble telescope i think is like
300 miles outside of
earth's orbit this is a million miles
away orbiting like around the sun
capturing images
5 billion light years away which is to
say 5 billion years into the past
and when you look at that image each
blob of light that you see there
um in the image is a galaxy
with it and each of those galaxies has a
like a hundred billion stars
and each of those galaxies is is it
millions of miles away millions of light
years away from each other yet they seem
so crowded together in the image
and yet
if you were to
hold up a grain of sand in front of your
face
it would block out this whole region of
space from your perspective
okay billions and billions and trillions
and zillions of miles with billions of
planets and suns
and nebula and galaxies and black holes
and probably millions of advanced
civilizations i'm assuming all of that
from our perspective
tinier
than a grain of sand on the beach
that
is interesting
you better be interested by it
if this doesn't interest you then i
don't know what else to tell i don't
know i don't know what to say i give up
let's get to our comment section
[Music]
given uh recent scotus wins it feels
like the pendulum may be swinging back
to a time when the nuclear family was
situated at the center of american life
we got a long way to go but maybe we're
headed there ever so
slowly where you know in this case real
conversation learning and growth begin
at home with your family gathered around
the table and president ronald reagan's
farewell address he said all great
change in america begins around the
dinner table bring your family to the
dinner table with good ranchers then
good ranchers cares deeply about
providing families with high quality
meat and doing it at a reasonable price
as always their mission is to bring
people to the table making those shared
moments with your loved ones easy
accessible and uh delicious as well good
rancher ships 100 american meat born
raised and harvested in the u.s right to
your door plus when you subscribe your
price is locked in for life uh the
entire time you're subscribed to them
you get the same price you know it's not
going to go up i've scarfed down
everything they sell my wife enjoys it
my kids as picky as they can be they
like sitting down when we're eating good
ranchers their t-bones rib eyes burgers
everything from them is great i haven't
been disappointed by anything good
ranchers not only supports american
agriculture they also are big fans of
the daily wire they sponsor all of our
shows so go check them out use my code
walsh for 30 bucks off
plus free shipping on your order take
advantage of this offer today you can
invest in time shared with your family
you're going to buy meat anyway buy
great meat from folks who support all
that we do here go to goodranchers.com
walsh to start bringing people back to
the table and eating seriously delicious
food
now we do have some comments from the
show yesterday but there were two others
that i neglected to read yesterday as we
were reading yesterday reading comments
from um
from a video released during during
vacation where i was ranking the worst
superheroes
and i was reading some comments from
some very angry nerds who were
mad that i was being disrespectful of
superheroes and superhero mythology i
just want to read two other comments to
you because these are great uh yakubu
says hey matt i just want to say you are
absolutely right you're not qualified to
make this judgment of superhero movies
if you think that the wonder woman
outfit isn't the right one for war
maybe if you research on the character
you'll know better
oh yeah wonder woman in
like a spandex leotard
fighting trench warfare that's the that
by the way also bright colored okay
bright colored
uh but the hair makeup is perfectly done
bright colored spandex uniform for
trench warfare
for 20th century trench warrior you
think that's the right outfit that's
what you would go with
if someone said to you if you got
enlisted to be involved in trench
warfare that you would say hello let me
go grab my spandex real quick
come on you kubo you know better dwight
says usually i'm very much in agreement
with matt walsh but i could not watch
this whole video
blatantly ripping female superheroes for
a show and trying to compare them to
realistic standards when they're
obviously fictional characters is
ridiculous and irresponsible everything
he's saying can be applied to male
superheroes if you utilize that same
logic the tone from the first eight
minutes i watched really makes it sound
as if he personally does not like
women's superheroes were they the
greatest movies no but find other
relevant topics come on man uh i just
love this type i love this comment for
so many reasons it's irresponsible so
this is like dangerous and irresponsible
to criticize female superheroes uh i'd
love to learn a little bit more about
that why it's irresponsible
you accuse me of not liking women
superheroes well i yes i'm guilty as
charged i'm not hiding that
but i also don't like any other
superheroes so you can rest easy i
suppose on that part of it and then you
complain about the topic itself we'll
find something else to talk about
you clicked on a video
where the title was ranking the worst
superheroes so it doesn't make any sense
to click on the content and then
criticize the content for existing
it may it's it's just like if i if i
walked in
to um
you know if i were jill biden walking
into a taco restaurant and then saying
why are you guys making tacos in here
why don't you make a pizza instead
if you want other content then just
don't click on that thing which is very
clearly labeled
all right let's go to some comments from
the actual show says um
h mill says
matt how are you so on top of things
already we just got back from vacation
with our six children had an amazing
time but i'm on my second day trying to
recover the suburban is still trashed
there's a mountain of laundry and
somehow the house is trashed when we
haven't been here we also brought home a
cold parents need at least a week to get
back to normal glad to have you back
uh yeah well this is all
this is all camera tricks i assure you
uh i i'm this is any parent knows this
that after going on vacation as a family
you need us you need another vacation
from the vacation
but part of the advantage i have is that
i'm still like semi on vacation i'm i'm
at least in the place where we
vacationed so uh but
make no mistake i can pull together
slightly a little bit for for camera not
even that well
but um
in reality i'm just falling apart in so
many ways william says matt is a
different kind of creature i honestly
don't think most people could handle the
attack that comes when you speak the
truth about gender not that i'm excusing
her giving into threats but i can't
imagine what it feels like to be
subjected to leftist attacks
so i kind of agree with jk rowling
standing up for her but i also agree
with matt
that it's better to stand your ground
in the long run
uh yeah
you know
yes it it's
difficult
when people are attacking you but
we can acknowledge that and i think
we've all acknowledged that and i
acknowledge that i've experienced it so
i know that it's difficult but once we
acknowledge that then we just have to
move on
because if we're going to tolerate that
as an excuse
indefinitely
then nothing's gonna ever get better
like if if you want
any kind of positive change in society
requires at least a little bit of
courage there's no way to do it without
courage
um courage is uh i think c.s lewis said
courage is the testing point of all
virtue
you can't really have any virtue if you
don't have courage
so what you're and
i i
appreciate
that you're trying to be empathetic
but at the same time what you're
basically saying is
yeah but you know if it requires courage
that we shouldn't expect people to do it
well that is also talk about giving up
on civilization i mean that's you're
just giving up or throwing up our hands
and we need to hold people to a higher
standard than that
yes it does require courage to stand up
against a mob
but
we all should expect each other to show
courage and if we don't we should be
held accountable
for that
um
let's see peanut pablo says i feel so
bad now because i'm blind and i have my
fiance drive me places i'll have to put
up with the judgment of sweet daddy
walsh and the sweet baby siblings
i hate to say it but um
you know just as i
know that uh that
i can't depend on any excuse when i when
i relinquish the steering wheel to my
wife even though i driven 17 hours and
she only drove two and
i felt like i was falling asleep at the
wheel so i had it but still it's not a
good excuse the man always drives and i
think um
even visual impairment is is just not
a satisfactory excuse i'm afraid to say
and finally jeremy says why is everyone
in the comments calling him sweet daddy
walsh
well here's someone who doesn't know the
first rule
of the sweet baby gang and is therefore
banned
but thanks for watching anyway
every day the universe is expanding and
we're learning more about it and how
interesting and fascinating it is both
the literal outer space version and also
our own daily wire plus multimedia
universe which is even more fascinating
than the actual universe as the world's
first non-woke streaming service daily
wire plus is everything you love about
the daily wire plus so much more as a
member you get exclusive access to new
shows and features from jordan peterson
plus the entire prageru library plus
animated and live action kids content
which is coming soon plus original
movies and documentaries all of that now
that i mentioned daily wire plus does
have this one gripping
transcended documentary in particular
that you should check out maybe you've
heard me mention a time or two it's
called what is a woman it has has a
score of 97 of rotten tomatoes from the
audience anyway uh the mainstream
critics have just completely ignored it
but the audience loves it and you could
watch what is a woman for yourself and
find out why you can also watch all of
our other great documentaries movies and
shows by going to dailywireplus.com or
download and open the daily wire app
today if you aren't yet a member you can
get 35 off when you sign up now it's
time to build the future you want to see
become a member at dailywireplus.com
today
now let's get to our daily cancellation
[Music]
well it's been a prolific week for
privilege uh it all began on saturday
with a rousing twitter debate about anne
frank's white privilege now apparently
some leftists on the platform had been
discussing
the issue of inherent privileges
allegedly enjoyed by victims of the
holocaust
and tmz was the first outlet to pick up
on this conversation and report on it
with the breathless and only
semi-coherent headline anne frank she
had white privilege twitter debates
tmz reports in their article twitter is
yet again proving it's the worst for
bulk bad takes this time debating
whether anne frank was hunted and killed
by nazis had white privilege while alive
then there's an emoji i don't even know
what that emoji is supposed to mean they
put it in the middle of like a news
article an emoji
then they continue you might have
noticed that uh
the late holocaust victim was trending
saturday but finding out why is
disheartening some it seems have floated
an argument that frank benefited from
white privilege in nazi germany an
argument that is rightly being shot down
left and right unclear how this toxic
discourse first started but it seems to
stem from a warped notion that jews had
the benefit of their skin color to go
unnoticed in public if only temporarily
during that bleak time in history while
poc
historically haven't been able to do so
the theory is so twisted and yet it's
being defended by a select few on the
bird app
now as always
the first thing that jumps out at you
anytime you read a tmz article is that
the film idiocracy had it wildly wrong
because in the movie it took 500 years
for the world to be so completely dumbed
down and stupefied that a guy with an iq
of 95 is the greatest genius on the
planet by all appearances we'll reach
that point probably in another i don't
know you know not 500 years maybe 500
minutes or so
as for the white privilege debate um tmz
may be scandalized by the very notion
that a 16 year old girl who died in the
holocaust could be
accused of having you know any kind of
privilege at all
and it is
an incredibly stupid idea but it's also
what leftism teaches the doctrine of
white privilege clearly states that
white people possess inherent privileges
on the basis of their race no exceptions
are made for this or can be made because
any exception would unravel the whole
idea of inherent privilege to begin with
if any individual white person can lose
their privilege or never possess it to
begin with it would prove that privilege
is not something automatically bestowed
on everyone based on skin pigmentation
and if that's the case then the white
privilege creed is invalid but the
invalidation of the white privilege
concept would mean the invalidation of
the left's entire racial project which
they can't allow to happen
this means that all white people
everywhere in all situations
must be indicted for possessing inherent
privilege no matter how invisible that
privilege may seem
holocaust victims had privilege uh the
white child born in a single wide
trailer to a meth addicted mother has
privilege the homeless white guy
sleeping under the bridge has privilege
the white college applicant denied
acceptance in favor of a less qualified
minority applicant has privilege
if you are white
even if you can find no evidence in your
life that you were ever given any
advantage because of your race and even
if on on the contrary there's actually
evidence that you've been disadvantaged
because of your race
you still have privilege
privilege is
unfalsifiable there is nothing you can
do to disprove it
and that includes being murdered in the
holocaust
if that sounds crazy to you well yes
exactly you're getting the point
but there are more developments on the
privilege front this weekend a tick tock
video went viral thanks to our friend
libs of tick tock featuring
an obese woman
explaining the concept of thin privilege
yes privilege is not just a signed on
based on race of course there are many
other forms of it as tick tock user gay
dhd goddess explains listen
i
have thin privilege
what
but i'm so fat i'm like a size 20 22.
how can i possibly have thin privilege
because there are people who are fatter
than me
when i go up on a plane
i might need a seatbelt extender i might
be uncomfortable i may not feel good
people may say thanks to me
but i don't need to buy a second seat or
risk getting kicked off the plane
that means that i have privilege
compared to people to have that
experience
you
may not even need a seat belt expend
extender if that's the case then you
have privilege compared to me
somebody who is a model size may have
privilege compared to you
but that doesn't mean you don't have any
privilege
almost all of us have something
privilege it's a spectrum and it goes by
degrees
right if you need a seat belt extender
you still have thin privilege because at
least you fit into one seat she says
she actually says that
and if you need two seats you still have
thin privilege compared to somebody who
takes up the whole row
and that person actually has thin
privilege compared to somebody who needs
to charter their own military cargo
plane just to get around and that person
has thin privilege compared to somebody
who can't fly at all and has to be tied
down to an aircraft carrier like king
kong and dropped off on a mythical
island filled with other prehistoric
beasts
as long as there's at least one other
life form theoretically more gargantuan
than you
you have thin privilege we're told
now you can kind of see the self-serving
i would really call it brilliance of the
thin privilege spectrum concept because
all at once it allows the fat person to
claim victim status you know competing
for gold in the oppression olympics
while at the same time rationalizing
their gluttony by also claiming finn
status in comparison to people fatter
than themselves
so they can have their cake and eat it
too in their case both figuratively and
i'm sure literally
the magic of intersectional victimology
all at one all at once makes them both
victims of fatness
and beneficiaries of fitness they can be
both
it's the best of both worlds or at least
it would be if the worlds actually
existed but they don't
because as a great philosopher once said
i think it was aristotle he said
quoting he said the mere existence of a
fatter ass
does not make your ass any less fat
thinness
you know may have a relative component
to it
for example
even after gorging myself on vacation
for a week and a half i am still thinner
than let's say a humpback whale
but that doesn't really mean anything
because if you're a human being
your thinness or fatness is judged
really not based on a comparison between
yourself and other species or even
between yourself and other people but
rather on how a human is supposed to be
built
the problem with being fat is that if
you are fat
you are carrying around more lard than
your body was made to handle and that
would be the case even if you were the
only person on earth
even if if you are morbidly obese and
everyone else dies and you're the last
person living you would still be fat
because
your body wasn't made to handle all that
fat you're over taxing your bones your
internal organs you're killing yourself
that would be the case no matter what el
what anybody else is doing
this is also why thin privilege makes no
sense
no matter what the left has tried to do
with the word
privilege
is quite simply as the dictionary still
defines it at least for now
a special right advantage or immunity
granted or available only to a
particular person or group that's a
privilege
um the ability to fit onto an airplane
seat is not a special right or advantage
the ability of my liver and lungs and
other internal organs to function
normally
is not a special right or advantage it's
simply the standard human experience
it's what we're supposed to all
experience
the obese person has inflicted upon
himself
special disadvantages
that doesn't make him a victim in any
kind of societal sense of the turn
the same can be can be applied to the
concept of racial privilege
if you as a white person
have never been explicitly granted
special rights or advantages or
immunities because of the color of your
skin then you don't have white privilege
okay if there if there is um
nothing
that you're like allowed to do
because you're white that other
non-white people aren't allowed to do if
then then you don't have white privilege
you might have other privileges
there are indeed privileges that come
with let's say being wealthy
uh there are privileges that come with
being extremely attractive
not that i would know is especially the
case if you're a woman all kinds of
privileges come with being an attractive
woman
and most of all there are privileges
granted on the basis of ideology
you you will enjoy
the support and encouragement of every
powerful institution in the country if
you're on the left side of the
ideological divide
that's the greatest privilege that our
society has to offer
it's where true privilege can be found
in many ways so ironically those
complaining about their lack of
privilege
are doing so in order to gain privilege
by professing the doctrine of privilege
they're publicly aligning themselves
with leftism and ensuring that they'll
be granted all the privileges that come
with it
and that is why
white privilege
and thin privilege and all the other
fallacious concepts of privilege are
today cancelled and we'll leave it there
for today thanks for watching thanks for
listening have a great day
godspeed
[Music]
the matt wall show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavel vadosky
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by jeff tomlin our
audio is mixed by mike cormina hair and
makeup is done by cherokee heart the
matte wall show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
jill biden compares hispanics to tacos
glen yunken figures out a way to rid
virginia of 300 useless government
bureaucrats and a gay couple sues when a
designer baby son turns out to be a
daughter what is a daughter check it out
on the michael knowles show